california es un estado en crisis 14.000
bomberos han pasado el fin de semana
tratando de contener más de dos docenas
de grandes incendios pero mientras que
el sábado los equipos tuvieron buen
tiempo los meteorólogos han emitido una
advertencia de bandera roja prediciendo
que el regreso de los fuertes vientos
los relámpagos y la poca lluvia
conducirán a más focos en llamas
es trágico pero nuestros jefes en casa
son agresivos en el entrenamiento que
tenemos en la respuesta al trabajo en
campo y nos preparamos adecuadamente
para ello para que podamos venir aquí a
ayudar a las comunidades donde estamos
llamados a servir
la mayoría de los focos están
localizados en el norte del estado cerca
de san francisco y la capital del estado
sacramento donde las llamas ya han
arrasado más de 400 mil hectáreas 700
hogares han sido devastados varias
personas han muerto y decenas de miles
han sido evacuadas a áreas más seguras
dijeron que estaríamos fuera una semana
probablemente pero las casas de las
zonas más altas de la montaña estamos
hablando de dos o tres semanas si es que
queda algo para que vuelvas un chico más
práctico tengo varios amigos que
perdieron sus casas y muchos más que
están evacuados así que es un momento
muy difícil pero es genial ver a la
comunidad unida para hacer lo que
podamos para apoyarnos unos a otros los
funcionarios de estado han advertido de
que lo peor aún no ha pasado y se ha
dicho que los residentes de pueblos como
santa cruz que hasta ahora no han sido
tocados por las llamas se preparen para
salir de sus casas en un breve plazo